>> Laura: FRIDAY NIGHT, THAT
MEANS IT IS TIME FOR FRIDAY
FOLLY.
A RADICAL PRIEST TRIES TO REHAB
FARRAKHAN?
A PANEL OF DEMOCRATS TO FIGHT
OVER 2020, AND ONE DAD YOU WANT
TO AVOID.
JOINING US NOW WITH THE DETAILS,
RAYMOND ARROYO, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR, AUTHOR, I THOUGHT
AFTER FARRAKHAN WAS BANNED FROM
FACEBOOK THAT, I DON'T KNOW, HIS
DAYS IN THE SPOTLIGHT MIGHT BE
COMING TO AN END BUT NOW A
CATHOLIC PRIEST IS TRYING TO
RESURRECT HIM.
>> LAURA, IT IS SIMPLY
UNBELIEVABLE.
A LEFTIST ACTIVIST, WHICH WE
WILL GET TO IN A MOMENT, HE
INVITED THE CONTROVERSIAL NATION
OF ISLAM LEADER TO SPEAK AT HIS
CHICAGO PARISH YESTERDAY.
THE REASON, HE WANTS FARRAKHAN
BACK ON FACEBOOK.
WATCH APPEAR TO.
>> MINISTER FARRAKHAN HAS BEEN A
BOLD VOICE AGAINST INJUSTICE
DONE AGAINST BLACK PEOPLE IN
THIS COUNTRY.
HIS VOICE DESERVES AND NEEDS TO
BE HEARD!
>> TO UNDERSCORE THE POINT, HE
BROADCAST LOUIS FARRAKHAN'S
VISIT TO THE PARISH FLOUTING IT
EVEN THOUGH HE WAS BANNED FROM
THE SOCIAL MEDIA SITE IN PART
BECAUSE OF HIS ALLEGEDLY
ANTI-SEMITIC SPEECH.
>> TO THE WHITE PEOPLE WHO THINK
I'M A HATER, YOU DON'T KNOW ME!
SOMEBODY MADE YOU HATE ME!
THIS IS JUST THE BEGINNING!
BANNING ME FROM A SOCIAL
PLATFORM!
I USED THAT PLATFORM WITH
RESPECT.
AND I'M HERE TO SEPARATE THE
GOOD JEWS FROM THE SATANIC.
>> HE IS OUT OF HIS MIND.
TO THINK THAT THIS IS
APPROPRIATE OR IN ANY WHERE
SOCIAL JUSTICE, TO BRING A MAN
LIKE THIS FLOUTING ANTI-SEMITISM
TO A CATHOLIC CHURCH, IT IS
AMAZING TO ME THAT CHICAGO
HASN'T INTERVENED HERE.
>> Laura: HE HAS BEEN DOING
THIS TYPE OF NONSENSE FOR YEARS,
YET THE VATICAN LOOKS THE OTHER
WAY, THERE IS NO COMMENT.
HE HAS BEEN A NIGHTMARE,
FRANKLY, FOR A LOT OF CATHOLICS
IN THE CHICAGO AREA AND FRANKLY
ACROSS THE COUNTRY FOR A LONG,
LONG TIME.
WE SHOULD'VE BROUGHT THEM ON THE
FACEBOOK PANEL A FEW MINUTES AG
AGO.
>> HERE'S THE THING, AT
ONE POINT, AMERICA HE SAID IS
THE GREATEST SIN AGAINST GOD AND
HE CALLED FOR A GUN OWNER WHO
OWNED A SHOP, HE ASKED PEOPLE TO
SNUFF OUT THE OWNER OF A
GUNSHOT.
NOW THE PRESIDENT OF THE
ILLINOIS HOLOCAUST MUSEUM,
HERSELF A SURVIVOR OF THE
HOLOCAUST SAID, "I DON'T
UNDERSTAND BECAUSE I'VE ALWAYS
THOUGHT HE WAS ONE FOR PEACE.
WHAT HE IS DOING TODAY AND WHAT
HE IS DOING WITH FARRAKHAN IS
GIVING HIM A PLATFORM FOR
HATRED, HATRED HE HAS SPOKEN FOR
MANY, MANY YEARS."
THIS IS HOPEFULLY NOT THE LAST
WE HEAR OF PEOPLE SPEAKING OUT
AGAINST THIS KIND OF HATRED.
>> Laura: TELL US ABOUT THE
CNN PANEL.
>> SPEAKING OF UNEXPECTED
REACTIONS, CNN GATHERED A PANEL
OF DEMOCRATS IN PENNSYLVANIA TO
TRY TO GET A PULSE ON HOW
DEMOCRATS ARE FEELING GOING INTO
2020.
THEN CAME THE ULTIMATE QUESTION.
>> HOW MANY OF YOU FEEL
CONFIDENT TODAY THAT A DEMOCRAT
WILL WIN IN 2020?
[RINGING]
>> LATER, A FIGHT BROKE OUT OVER
THE GENDER OF THE DEMOCRATIC
NOMINEE OR WHAT IT SHOULD BE.
>> I STILL DON'T KNOW IF THE
COUNTRY IS READY FOR A WOMAN.
I THINK THEY ARE.
>> IF THEY ARE NOT READY, WE
HAVE TO MAKE IT READY.
IT IS TIME FOR A WOMAN TO RUN
THIS COUNTRY.
WHY NOT?
>> I WANT A WOMAN PRESIDENT MORE
THAN ANYTHING ELSE IN THIS
WORLD.
WHEN I WAS A LITTLE GIRL, I
WANTED TO BE THE FIRST WOMAN
PRESIDENT.
>> Laura: THAT'S NICE.
WHEN I AM TRYING TO GET OVER IS
ALLISON SAYING THIS, AFTER ONLY
TWO OR THREE PEOPLE RAISED THEIR
HANDS, HM.
WHAT PRODUCER IS GOING TO GET
THE BOOST BECAUSE OF THIS
EMBARRASSING PANEL?
>> YOU SAW SOMETHING VERY
ILLUSTRATIVE THERE.
YOU ARE SEEING A GLIMPSE OF THE
2028 DEMOCRATIC PARTY APPEARED
AT THE MOMENT, THEY LACK UNITY,
THERE IS NO CLEAR GOVERNING
AGENDA OR SOMETHING TO RALLY
THEM TOGETHER EXCEPT HATRED OF
TRUMP.
THAT IS IT.
WHAT YOU ARE SEEING AND I THINK
YOU ARE GOING TO SEE MORE OF IS
A COLLAPSE INTO GENDER AND
IDENTITY POLITICS THAT COULD RIP
THEM APART.
REALLY, THAT COULD BE A
MULTI-HEADED HYDRA GOING INTO
2020 AND PAVING THE WAY FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
LAURA, WE'VE BEEN HAVING SOME
VERY BAD WEATHER DOWN HERE IN
LOUISIANA WHERE I AM RIGHT NOW
AND AT THE OTHER DAY, A LOCAL
REPORTER DECIDED TO USE A PROP
TO SHOW HOW HIGH THE WATER WAS.
HE DECIDED TO USE A CRAWFISH.
BAD CHOICE.
>> A NUMBER OF PEOPLE ARE
ACTUALLY HERE LOOKING FOR
CRAWFISH.
THEY ACTUALLY JUST GOT ME ON TV.
WOW, THAT HURT.
>> [LAUGHS]
IF THE ONLY KIND OF CRAWFISH IS
THAT HAS BEEN BOILED AND YOU
SNAP ITS HEAD OFF.
THAT IS THE ONLY KIND.
>> Laura: I THOUGHT IT WAS
GOING TO BE THE OTHER DAY WHEN
THEY RANG THE DOORBELL, I
THOUGHT THIS WAS A CRAWFISH
BITING HIM ON THE NOSE.
THE FINGER?
WE WANT THE WHOLE NOSE TAKEN
OFF, OKAY?
NOT REALLY, IT'S JUST FUNNY OR
TAKEN THAT WAY.
>> I KNOW.
THIS SATURDAY, A BOOK SIGNING AT